hey 42 here from my research one thing
has become extraordinarily clear if you
wish to become famous and I mean really
famous so famous that people still talk
about you years after your death there
are two incredibly effective strategies
that you can attempt right now
the first is to immediately let go of
all worldly ambition have a general
disinterest in money and worldly
pleasures and travel from town to town
highlighting social injustices and
preaching brotherly love adopt
strategies like forgiveness and pacifism
and use phrases like the kingdom of God
is within you
and generally speak with great passion
about the equality between old peoples
and the need for selfless love this
strategy is almost guaranteed to make
you indelibly famous in world history
but it is also guaranteed to get you
assassinated crucified and otherwise
brutally killed the second option which
is even riskier is to choose your moment
wealth strike when your nation is
downtrodden launch a campaign of
nationalism and racial hatred and take
on all of Europe Russia and just about
the entire world in all-out war follow
this again will result in your death or
at least being frozen on ice in a secret
Argentinian bunker it will also
guarantee a level of Fame that ensures
that years later you will never be more
than a few clicks away from anyone on
Wikipedia
not bad right so yeah almost certain
death but astronomical levels of fame
who wouldn't want to make that trade
fame is a strange phenomenon that can
seem somewhat hard to pin down the
cambridge english dictionary defines it
as the state of being known or
recognized by many people because of
your achievements and skills it's a
level of social standing prestige and
worldwide attention that is attained for
various reasons such as sporting ability
financial income performance art or
birthright basically anything that means
you get mentioned over and over again by
the press because
you want to get famous getting talked
about by the press is pretty much
mandatory a lot of people incorrectly
believe that fame is fleeting that
whilst we may be in the spotlight one
moment we'll just too swiftly be out of
it the next and tossed aside like
yesterday's jam but the research on fame
resents different picture a 2013 study
published in the American Sociological
review found that rather than lasting 15
minutes fame hangs around for decades
with the most famous and most frequently
mentioned celebrities showing up time
and time again take that's on the Warhol
who by the way coins the 15 minutes of
fame Maxim I don't just have an
irrational hatred of condensed soup well
perhaps a little so once you've acquired
Fame you'll probably have it for life
for better or for worse but how exactly
do you acquire it well research shows
that one crucial factor is your age
whilst in the 19th century the typical
famous person became renowned around
their mid forties this number has been
steadily declining
researchers at Harvard analyzed 740,000
Wikipedia entries on famous people and
calculated that 29 is the median age
people become famous today your career
is also a consideration actors can
become famous relatively young whereas
politicians become worldwide figures
often overnight but typically later in
their life
take for example Barack Obama who went
from somewhat nobody new to the most
famous man in the world in a few months
this is largely the rule for all
politicians Donald Trump excluded who
had already spent much of his career
gaining notoriety by pointing at
hopeless idiots across tables creating
fake universities and well this
but in general there are a few quick
ways to become famous such as developing
an enormous talent for acting singing or
a sporting skill the more skill usually
the greater the fame
likewise new technologies and platforms
have allowed relative unknowns to reach
Fame overnight YouTube is one of these
but without a mustache like this you're
[ __ ] out of luck but what are the real
strategies that you can use to get
famous what are the secrets that
celebrities are hiding that once
revealed you can use to catapult
yourself into a position of worldwide
adulation well there are a few but I
have some terrible terrible news the
odds of you becoming famous kind of suck
and buy kinda suck I mean well let's put
it kindly it's never going to happen in
2013 a journalist for Wired looked
through the category of living people
and Wikipedia and tallied the total
amounts of entries he found that there
were around 600,000 then in order to
calculate the likelihood of becoming
famous he set that against a global
population of over 7 billion taking that
same methodology in 2020 the number of
living famous people is over nine
hundred and fifty five thousand hands
the world population is over seven point
seven eight three billion which means
the odds of you becoming famous now are
zero point zero zero zero one two two
seven zero for free or about one in
eight thousand one hundred and fifty you
are almost equally or even more likely
to die of accidental gun discharge one
in nine thousand choking on food one in
2,600 or being burnt alive in a fire one
in 1400 to say nothing of heart disease
which is almost definitely going to kill
60% of the people watching this video
hell you even have a 1 in 300 chance of
getting shot to death although by a
sardonic irony your assailant will
probably gain much more fame than you do
now you're probably thinking this
mustache twirling idiot doesn't know a
damn thing he doesn't know just how much
potential I've got I'm definitely
to be famous all right let's say you've
got the potential to get famous before
you choke to death on a crab leg let's
take a look at the most reliable ways to
increase your chances well there are a
few strategies that celebrities have
used that on the surface may look like
they would work for you but in reality
they almost definitely won't and I'll
explain why let's start with Dwayne
Johnson aka the rock arguably the most
famous actor in the world
if he is 182 million Instagram followers
not to be believed the rock famously
started his wrestling career of seven
dollars in his pocket worked his ass off
dominated the WWE then transitioned to
the acting world where he became the
highest-paid on earth he's notorious for
his incredible work his free to five
hours sleep a night and incredible
charisma unsure if you worked harder got
a better sleeping routine and worked on
your social skills your odds of becoming
a famous wrestler would probably
increase however you'd be missing an
important ingredient that the rock also
had his father was already a
world-famous wrestler for the WWE their
first black champion in fact he trained
his son in wrestling was instrumental in
getting him a WWF development deal and
even returned to the ring to help his
son out in matches so unless your dad is
elbow dropping people off the top rope
and know the pup doesn't count
you can probably rule a swift path to
fame out another example of an
incredible and almost preposterous rise
to fame is the Kardashian family these
self-made or rather ass made gazillion
heirs stand alongside the Royals as
perhaps the most famous and beloved
family in the world
if one totally disregard self-respect
the Kardashians are perhaps the most
intelligent marketers around they have
an innate knowledge on how to gain
attention maintain
their spot in the public eye not only
that they're talented entrepreneurs with
Kylie Jenner being the youngest
self-made billionaire on earth and
undoubtedly if you learns to market
yourself of the same dedication
accurately read the public mood and
capitalize on it with viral content
you'd no doubt increase your odds of
becoming famous
however the Kardashians had not one but
two famous dance are you starting to
notice a trend here Rob Kardashian was a
high-powered attorney who defended non
avert than OJ Simpson hands their own
father Bruce Jenner was a multiple gold
winning decathlete so famous she's now
an even more famous woman called Caitlyn
not only that puts the de facto leader
of the Kardashians
Kim happens to be childhood friends with
none other than Paris Hilton who
demonstrated in clear steps how to gain
the public's attention and ride a sex
tape to fame they say you're the sum
total of everyone you hang around with
and if everyone around you is rich and
famous and good at getting attention
odds are you'll probably be the same now
this isn't to say someone like Kylie
isn't as savvy entrepreneur she
definitely is but Kylie down the street
doesn't exactly have the same chances
when it comes to getting her business
idea the attention and investment it
needs whereas a person with an
influential family can put cat piss in a
bottle and attract millions of dollars
of investments now you might say that
I'm being too cynical hardwork after all
does pay off Michael Jordan came out of
nowhere
worked his ass off and became the
greatest NBA player of all time but not
just that a worldwide sporting and
marketing phenomenon he had little
outside help and succeeded both on and
off the court as a result of his
insatiable competitive drive and
unfaltering work ethic but whilst a lot
of us would like to be like Mike how
many of us actually are
and is working hard and having
guaranteed positive outcomes actually a
choice you possess or does look or
something more subconscious in your mind
play much more of a parts than we'd all
like to believe it's difficult to say
and the cutting-edge research into the
mind suggests our ability to exert
control over these kinds of decisions is
more difficult than just a simple choice
for example Nobel Prize winner and
author of Thinking Fast and Slow Daniel
Kahneman 'he's work has demonstrated
that human decisions are sometimes slow
and logical but equally they are
sometimes quick and unconscious and that
the whole system of human judgment isn't
something to put much confidence in what
this means for you is that whilst it may
seem easy and effortless to replicate
the same choices and judgments as famous
people such as work hard in practice
you'll find it far more difficult and
subject to differing unconscious choices
that you aren't even aware of bit of a
downer I know but don't worry you might
be able to sidestep that together that
is if you were born in the right place
right off the bat it would seem obvious
that a country like America which seems
to mass-produce celebrities would be the
best place to be born
however with its swelling population of
328 million it may be better to start
your quest to fame in a smaller less
populous nation like New Zealand where
athletes like the All Blacks or
filmmakers like Taika Waititi and Peter
Jackson stand out all the more not to
disparage their incredible achievements
however if you are born in America then
growing up in states like New York
Massachusetts and Illinois will for
reasons largely unknown increase your
likelihood of become
famous all what is known is that each
state produces more than six celebrities
per 100,000 people which is quite a lot
with New York producing over 15
similarly perplexing is the fact that
being born under the right star sign may
help but don't get me started on that
one I can only tell you that of the
Forbes list of 100 celebrities over 12%
of them were born under Taurus which is
good news if you happen to share the
same star sign
however Sagittarius only accounts for
2.7 percent perhaps it was all the
horsing around ha but let's look at a
tried and tested real world technique
something you can really sink your teeth
into well throughout history and perhaps
even more so today one of the most
effective techniques for gaining Fame is
to create a crapload of outrange
our most recent example of this has been
Canadian professor psychologist and
author Jordan Peterson although a
talented professor an engaging speaker
Peterson's rise to fame came not off the
back of his wide-ranging lectures but
because he was incredibly politically
and socially polarizing in 2016
Peterson took on the Canadian Bill c60
which aims to make gender identity and
expression as prohibited grounds of
discrimination resisting it as compelled
speech Peterson shot her fame when a
video was released of him debating with
a group of trans students during a
demonstration the video soon went viral
reposted by others with titles like
Professor destroy his triggered liberal
students and saw him invited to appear
on countless YouTube channels podcasts
and mainstream media interviews so
things snowballed on and on until he
appeared on popular podcast like Joe
Rogan and even debated so-called
journalist [ __ ] chocolate fire guard
Kathy Newman on channel 4 in a video
that went viral reposted by others with
titles like Professor destroys chicken
liberal interviewer a religious radical
in a robe pissed off the religious
conservatives of his day only to be
nailed to a cross and spawn the most
successful religion in
human history he became so famous in
fact that people now spontaneously
shouts his name when something shocking
happens especially when Lego bricks and
bare feet are involved in many ways this
is the most lasting form of fame as
being politically or religiously
polarizing it tends to galvanize our
movements of like-minded individuals
around you that continue your fame long
after you're gone
Christians Muslims Buddhists Nazis Klan
members and Scientologists all continue
to exist for this very reason
and I'm sure beliebers will exist
thousands of years from now executing
droves of Swifties by firing squad which
sounds like an incredible idea for a new
reality TV show there is an incredibly
easy way to become famous that I've kind
of failed to mention I'm of course
referring to being extraordinarily
good-looking with the rise of social
media there has never been a more
effective and perhaps more vacuous way
to gain Fame all you need is some
well-placed cheekbones a decent figure
and some provocative outfits and you'll
be on your way to becoming an only fans
sensation like a Stanny tea vendor
Arshad Khan discovered this for himself
firsthand well not the only fans part
one well-timed photo went viral and
Arshad went from being a humble
Pakistani chai wallah to being a
professional model who took the social
media world by storm all because he had
striking guys and a nice face in fact
looks are so important to social media
that tick-tock moderators were revealed
to have been instructed to suppress
videos of ugly poor or disabled to users
after all he wants to look at them when
you can look at video after video of
rich attractive girls twerking
there's also another almost foolproof
way to gain fame one you can do
overnight do you know what it is that's
right you can inherit it and Donald
Trump is probably the most famous man on
the planet not only is he the President
of the United States but he has an
incredible ability to dominate the press
every time he opens his mouth like him
or not he is a genius marketer who seems
incredibly adept at getting people to
give him attention and follow what he
says and knows how to play right into
the hands of reactionary liberals to his
own advantage
but his rise to fame isn't quite as
self-made as he likes to make out an
investigation by the New York Times
revealed that as young as age 3 he was
receiving $200,000 a year from his
father's Empire by age 8
this same Empire had made him a
millionaire and in his 40s and 50s it
was giving him over 5 million dollars a
year to top it off the small loan of 1
million dollars his father gave him to
start his career was actually closer to
60 point 7 million in short he didn't
exactly have the same start in life you
are I did so whether or not you have his
same skill at getting the press to talk
about you by simply tweeting hilariously
incorrect spelling of coffee your odds
of having the same volume of capital to
back up that attention are exceptionally
low people like Donald Trump and Kylie
Jenner get funding very few else ever
receive
in fact opportunity like this on the
kind repeatedly referred to in this
video is often overlooked when the
famous charts their rise to the top
perpetuating myths about Fame which
simply aren't true such as it's solely
about hard work and perseverance wealth
doesn't just create opportunity but it
also attracts attention the breeding
ground for fame wealthy affluent
lifestyles are over-represented in
social media right down to the
neighborhoods where the photographs are
taken this has led some to even seek to
fake their wealth to get social media
attention youtuber Christian Adam gee he
landed a couple of thousand new
followers by simply faking his wealth
using clever Photoshop manipulation so
perhaps learning some photoshop skills
and dropping $600 on a 24 hour
Lamborghini rental for an Instagram
photo is your best bet for
acquiring Fame but maybe you shouldn't
because being famous is actually very
overrated Fame as well as other
motivations like wealth are all
extrinsic motivations they're all things
you acquire from others or in the
material world but studies have shown
these kinds of goals to be psychological
dead ends that provide next to none of
the rewards granted by intrinsic
motivations these are the kind of
motivations deeply linked to who we are
what we value and what satisfies our
needs for autonomy competence and
relatedness to put it simply if you seek
purpose and accomplishment over shallow
Fame you'll probably live a much happier
life and to top it off one 2012 study
found that the desire to be famous
was deeply linked to narcissism and the
2013 study went deeper highlighting how
the desire for fame and the fantasizing
that accompanies it is used as a kind of
soothing balm for anxieties about social
exclusion that is to say not all but
many you seek Fame for fames sake are
trained to cover up their personal
misgivings which in the long run isn't a
healthy way to do so which begs the
question why do you really want to be
famous thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video then please consider
supporting me on patreon because it
really helps me to continue to make them
the links in the description also you
can get your hands on a first edition
signed copy of my new book stick if
liking it
by heading on over to unbound publishing
the links in the description and
pre-ordering yours today thank you